[Music]
if you look at where we are today a visa
vie where we were 40 years ago in health
care overall it's a phenomenal success
story we've added 35 years to life in
the last hundred years combination of
Public Health and and medical
advancement but because we have done so
well in keeping you live a long time
we've increased the cost cardiac care in
the 1970s was cheap because there was
nothing we could do for you today it's
expensive because we can do lot and the
new advances coming out every day will
record us will allow us to do more if
you had a bad hip in the 1970s what was
the answer
suck it up you want to play golf fair
you know play a little less golf today
we can do a hip replacement in 38
minutes because we really keep people
live longer they live into their 80s and
90s the bulk of expert help care
expenditures are spent on people all the
people at the end of life the last
year-and-a-half of life and also because
we can keep you alive longer we have now
new diseases that are occurring that we
didn't have before like Alzheimer's you
can't be talking about all of those
great things and at the same time
talking about well you know we spend 6
percent of all G&P in the 1960s and
healthcare why are we spending 17
percent today because we can do a heck
of a lot more today that does not mean
that we don't have efficiencies we can
get out of it we need to work on or that
we are not inefficient in certain areas
so that we don't overspend in certain
areas but I'm a big believer that the
overall cost of healthcare will never
come down the best you will be able to
do is slow the rate of growth that's
different from what we should be doing
to make sure that people's out-of-pocket
expenses don't become a barrier to
getting care but two definitions people
confuse them all the time people say I
have to pay more out of my pocket
therefore healthcare is costly yeah but
you're not going to fix the overall cost
you've got to fix this issue the overall
cost if cost growth can be reduced but
coming from 70
of GNP 2/10 of synergy never happened
[Music]